CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here for a look at the
business of Black Friday Joe I know
people are gonna spend but I hear you
talk about a potential recession maybe
so why are people spending you know the
economy slowed down from last year to
this year we're growing at about two
percent but the really key point is that
employment is pretty good in fact we see
a lot more people who have jobs this
year the unemployment rate is near a
50-year low three point six percent and
that boosts confidence and as a result I
think that people are feeling like hey
you know what I got a little bit of a
wage increase inflation is pretty low
I've got more money I'm going to spend
this year your case study is Macy's in
terms of luring people into the stores
but they're they're having somewhat of a
bump in the road yeah it's it's really
interesting because we always hear about
the brick-and-mortar retailers that are
having a hard time but they're being
smart in that they're trying to lure us
in with the thing they have an advantage
over it is actually a book you're able
to go in and see and touch and feel
something try it on but the cost of
bringing people into your store has
actually started to rise and as a result
companies like Macy's or Kohl's or
JCPenney or Gap they are under quite a
bit of pressure at least their stock
prices this year and so what are they
doing to try to bring those people in
because you see these pop-up stores you
see hotels now right using these models
to try to get people to buy their
products so this is called experiential
marketing and they are trying to bring
you in with an experience so there could
be a store that says hey we're gonna
have a wine and cheese tasting or it
could be even really even more creative
and say you want to try a parka and
those boots on we're gonna have a cold
room you can try them on in that area
it's also do being really smart -
combining online with brick-and-mortar
order online pick it up on the store and
then there you can try it on what about
this notion we've been hearing for years
that brick-and-mortar is dead or in the
process of dying okay so what you will
hear throughout this weekend is the
growth of cyber is double-digit 14 15
percent from a year ago and then when
you hear about the actual sales total
there it's a much lower growth rate so
cyber is growing at a much more rapid
rate however
brick-and-mortar still accounts for most
shopping in this country about 90% in
brick-and-mortar now that even do yeah
well that includes car dealerships so we
have to put that in there but it's
really it's it's very important to
realize brick-and-mortar is not dead
this is called multi-channel experience
for retail and I really want to tell
people check your prices out online then
go to the stores you'll be much smarter
shelfs lessons are always in the note
thank you Jim